the Cleveland Browns continue to clean
up on aisle three as it relates to the
report last week from mark my losses of
WFAN that the Browns were talking to the
Vikings about a potential trade that
would have sent odo Beckham jr. from
Cleveland to Minnesota and what was
strange about this one Paul DePodesta
the Browns chief strategy officer came
out on Thursday and said on the record
on the record in his name in his voice
no misunderstanding no confusion that
the report was completely false okay
fine end of story reports completely
false we understand your position even
though we don't necessarily believe it
because sometimes a team finds itself in
a must lie situation because if they did
talk to the Vikings about a possible
trade for Odell Beckham jr. and if it
either fell through or got tabled the
last thing Paul DePodesta is going to
say publicly is yeah we had some
conversations about trading Odell
Beckham jr. but it didn't work out and
we hope Oh Beckham jr. will continue to
be happy here even though we were
talking about trading him somewhere else
no that's not gonna work it's especially
not gonna work with odo Beckham jr. you
can't do that we've seen it time and
again
look teams lie all the time for
strategic reasons and after the fact
when we catch them in a lie as fans and
media we don't get upset about it
because we understand that there are
circumstances where a team must lie but
then there's this strange disconnect
when they are potentially lying to our
faces too many of us just accept it as
the truth even though we have seen time
and again after the fact that it was a
lie or we understand that they have to
lie about it something strange happened
yesterday in this odo Beckham jr. story
even though Paul DePodesta was on the
record Thursday saying that the rumors
the reports whatever of a potential
traded the Vikings are completely false
an unnamed brown source told Adam
Schefter of ESPN the same thing you just
said it three days ago just set it in
Paul D Podesta's name and now you got a
leak to shefter on Sunday that it's not
true that there were no talks at all and
that's the truth
anytime and this is where I think the
reporters have an obligation to serve as
maybe a little bit of a BS filter here
you're gonna tell me that someone whose
name you won't tell me is saying that's
the truth well you can take that to the
bank
because well I can't tell you who said
it the whole thing is just a little bit
ridiculous but it just shows how
important it is for the Browns
to put out any potential brush fire with
Odell Beckham jr.
because if they did talk to the Vikings
or anyone else about a trade and it got
out which it did now you got a potential
problem with Beckham and you got to do
everything you can to ensure that
Beckham doesn't implode I heard some
coffee pouring in my ear which tells me
we may have Chris Sims back Chris are
you back I'm back I don't know what the
hell happened I hate technology that's
what I know I'm up first I'm glad you're
not the general manager of the New York
Giants yeah that's right yep because I
would be like the first glitch I'd have
during the first round of the draft I
would break iPads and computers over by
me I don't know why my iPad certainly
dropped the call and I couldn't get a
call back on the iPad it would only go
through my phone so I'm back here and I
do think you know they'll seconds.you is
there a chance Phillip is playing
fortnight no he's not he's still in bed
right now so yes no there's no excuse I
don't know what the hell happened
go ahead on you're Beckham thoughts well
I don't think I don't think the Odell
Beckham jr. trade rumors are real I
don't you know I've got nothing to lead
me to believe that to this point you
know you know I don't know maybe there
was a phone call maybe there was
something doing just checking about
availability I have no inside
information there to tell you about but
III don't I can't say I just haven't
heard it anything substantial for me to
sit here and go oh I believe that and
you know I heard what you said about
Adam Schefter and DePodesta and all
those things you know I get what you're
saying to a degree there but I also
think like DePodesta could have been the
original guy to text Adam Schefter like
there's no way that's happening and then
DePodesta has the press conference and
then puts his name to it that way so
no no no but Chris Chris he put his name
to it on Thursday and shefter had the
report three days later that's what's
weird about it
the guy's already on the record saying
it's completely false the Browns felt
compelled to tell shefter unnamed source
style that there was nothing to it I
think at this point whether there was or
wasn't any trade talks with the Vikings
or anyone else I think they're doing
extensive damage control to try to make
sure oh no Beckham Junior doesn't check
out saying maybe I want to be traded
well III agree with that I mean they
gotta be careful yes you know Odell
Beckham jr. you know as we know yeah
sure he's certainly not shy about
speaking his mind a little bit okay and
then also I think the one thing we know
is he's liked in that Cleveland rock
locker room too you know and I think if
you did him dirty it's gonna piss Jarvis
Landry off cuz I'm not so sure how happy
he is and it could be a ripple effect
through that locker room so I don't if I
was Cleveland first off there's just no
way I would trade Odell Beckham jr. and
certainly not for a second and a fit
right now with his current contract
situation and as talented he is as a
football player so I don't I don't
understand that and you know I really
think the Odell Baker Mayfield Jarvis
Landry Nick Chubb combination has a
chance to be really special like they
have a chance this year to make a run
and be legit don't ruin it now in the
offseason and trade away your most
explosive offensive asset and you know
Marc Millis has doubled down on Friday
talking about how he got the information
of course he can't disclose his sources
but you know it's not out of the
question that the Vikings approached the
Browns there's the pipeline there
between Mike Zimmer Rick Spielman and
Kevin Stefanski who worked for the
Vikings from 2006 through the completion
of the 2019 season so it's very easy to
break the ice and write the Vikings
offer to two and a five and the brown
said that ain't getting it done right
well think about it okay no we're not
doing it and that would qualify as
discussions on a possible trade that
would have involved a two and a five but
the Browns ultimately say no way in hell
but Chris your honor point is this the
point is this we we see this all the
time where teams deny
things and then they go ahead and do it
yeah so that's what makes it even harder
in a situation where we're trying
prospectively to figure out what the
truth is because there is an established
history of teams lying and then doing
that thing that they said they weren't
gonna do well yeah I mean there's no
doubt about that I mean oh we can't
listen to any of these coaches GM's
we've had how many have we had just lie
to our face write to us you know you
know whether it be brick Spielman or you
know Nick Saban back in the day you know
with the Dolphins whoever it may be
there's been plenty of examples of that
I understand then what Rick never lied
to us in 2013
Roy yet we have no intent to trade percy
harvin and they had no intent at the
time and then they did Annie we gave him
a chance to say we have no intent to
trade since to bond eggs and he said
Stefon Diggs is a Minnesota Viking which
was 100% accurate at the time it was
100% accurate
you're right very good job of wiggling
out mr. Szpilman but the English
language very good job you're right he
didn't lie to us I don't want to call
him a liar all right but but either way
you know even to the mark malicious
report you know that the way I envision
that happening and you know like I said
last week I know moose they call him up
here in the New York area he's a great
guy I would imagine if those calls were
made Mark malucia's probably found out
from somebody within the Giants
organization I would think somebody from
Minnesota called the Giants to dig up
some dirt and then maybe a guy like Mark
malucia's heard from somebody he's
connected to with the Giants that
Minnesota was calling about Odell
Beckham jr. and maybe that's where this
started so you know that that to me
again I have no knowledge of that but
that's just how I would connect the dots
on this in this type of situation
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports